okay next speaker Sanjay sasha is going
to talk about verification right thank
you for inviting me so I work in an area
called formal verification more
generally formal methods and I will tell
you what that's about in a minute but I
think at a very high level this area one
of the things about this area is that
the problems are hard in the
computational sense to start with so we
start with NP and we go higher and and
so that's why one of the reasons why
it's actually a good place to look for a
structure that might explain why in
spite of problems being you know very
high complexity or even undecidable in
practice we're able to solve these
problems in an industrial context okay
so the other thing I will say is that
i'm going to talk about three
explorations spread over ten years
approximately and is very little really
understood about the structure of
problems in my field and so I think it's
perfect for this workshop because you
know there's there's a lot of industrial
successes but we don't understand why
we're having these successes in from a
theoretical sense okay so what is formal
verification well basically the essence
is it's about computational proof
combination improving right so
algorithmic ways of proving or
disproving that a program p satisfies a
property Phi ok I'm going to I'm going
to use the term program but you know you
can think of it as a circuit or a model
of a system that has both discrete and
continuous components in it whatever
okay it's kinds of things that
verification is applied to can be very
diverse but let's think of them as
programs that have to satisfy properties
in the abstract okay so i want to
mention to areas where formal
verification is has found industrial
success the first is in the design of
digital circuits so micro processors
asics things like that and in fact one
of the places where formal verification
is routinely used i mean really every
digital circuit goes through this
process is equivalence checking
so the equivalence taking problem is
that you have two implementations of
what should be the same boolean function
so there's two combinational circuits
and you want to check that they are
functionally equivalent that they are
the same boolean function in one place
this happens is in the compiler tool
chain for circuits where you start with
a high-level programming language and
then you turn it into gates and you want
to make sure that these two
implementations are the same and so it's
easy to see that the underlying
conformational problem is sat right but
in spite of that you know equivalence
checking since the mid-1990s has been
part of the tool flow and there are
commercial tools sold and this advance
in practice on these industrial designs
and so that mean that's obviously the
question you know is that easy for these
instances okay so that's one thing we
talked about today the second area where
it's increasingly being used is in the
design of embedded software so embedded
software is the software that runs in
everyday objects so in avionics has been
has been a big customer of formal
verification from the beginning because
of the obvious safety critical nature
but increasingly automobiles are another
area where there's increasing need for
verification and people are looking at
the tools and with IOT spreading you
know this is going everywhere now what
are the some of the key questions here
so you have programs and you want to
verify safety properties of programs
that they they don't make out of bounds
accesses to memories that will then
cause the program to crash and lead to
some bad failure make things like that
okay what are the underlying
computational problems here is very
diverse it's not as clean as that but
one of the things that has to be done is
something called invariant inference
I'll explain that but also theorem
proving and the class of theorem proving
that has become very popular in
industrial practice is called
satisfiability modular theories just
think of this as SAT with richer types
so you don't just have boolean variables
but you have integer variables you have
variables that take array types you know
trees you know more richly destructions
okay all right so I'll talk a little bit
about this as well today
right okay so at a high level how does
formal verification work where you have
your program P and you have your
property Phi and the first step really
is to generate a formal model yeah
question is so the use of verification
and embedded system is is that as
successful as what is its growing that's
why it's not routine but it's like I
mean that's the this is this is where
all the demand is from industry these
days I'm just asking about not about the
roof yeah yeah yes yes there are success
stories and I can mention but I mean the
reason I have the Airbus here is because
their bus uses formal verification and
in fact we talked a little bit about how
that relates to the typical case
structure okay so thorough I pillow is
another big i mean i can i can mention
various in destructively if you want
alright so so the way this works is you
take the program in the property you
generate an internal formal model which
which typically has to have hills to the
approver so that it can actually make
progress and then at some point you
throw it over to a solver could be a Sat
solver or smt solver model check or
something and the solver turns away and
may need more hints and this process
iterates until you get an answer
hopefully so let's look at a toy example
and see how this may work so here's a
little program and so there's two
variables x and y x is assigned the
constant see why is assigned 0 then you
have a while loop so while x is greater
than equal to 0 you decrement x and then
there's some non deterministic function
that returns non-domestic returns 0 1
imagine this is something that we are
abstracting away we don't want to model
the details but if that returns true
then you ain't you increment Y and then
you go back okay so we I balling this we
can see that if X starts at sea and it
gets decremented by one in each
iteration then after c plus 1 iterations
it should quit and why it gets
incremented each time so it starts at
zero it should end at atmos c plus 1
okay so we expect that assertion to be
true now how would a verifier deal with
it
well this is a program that has a loop
so it turns out what you need is
something called a loop invariant the
loop invariant essentially is is a
property that holds at this point in the
program and if you go once around the
loop the property is still true okay so
that's what the invariant means so I
won't write down the exactly invading
for this program but the idea is there
is some invariant l and that allows you
to not have to reason about the number
of iterations of the loop explicitly
instead what you do is you break the
proof up into three steps so the first
step is the the so the initial condition
circle proof by induction basically the
initial condition says that if X is
initially is C and y is 0 and when this
condition is true then the loop
invariant holes and then the second one
says that if that if the loop condition
is true and the loop invariant holds
initially then after you go once around
the loop which is X is updated to X
prime Y is ablated y prime the loop
invariant holds on the prime variables
okay and then the last part says once
the loop exits the invariant is still
true and the assertion must hold so so
you break this up into basically
answering the conjunction of three
logical queries you want each of these
to be logically valid right so it's true
for all values of x and y and this
particular formula is over let's think
of these as integer variables so so this
is this would be a theorem tubing or as
SMP solving question over integer linear
rithmatic right so that's the that's
idea so you call the theorem prover and
you ask it is it valid ok so yes L is
not updated you so the idea is that
let's assume magically somebody gives
you l so that's gonna be a formula in
terms of x and y and so you just have
you just plug in that I'll talk about
later this is also an important problem
they how do you come up with L right and
sir L is a formula that's right and what
are the variables
the program tables yeah and you're
ignoring termination I'm uh well I mean
the idea is that the loop invariant
that's right so you can basically saying
if it terminates then the property holds
right of course you could try to prove
termination but I'm gonna ignore that
for now if then else so all right so
again this is the picture I showed you
earlier right and so one of the key
steps in this model generation is the
synthesis of the loop invariant right L
okay that's actually a key combination
problem that the verification community
spends a lot of time on the second part
is remember it was reasoning over
integer variables so you need it really
not a Sat solver but something higher
level smt solver but the way SMT solvers
work is by reduction to sat right this
is true of all SMB solvers all the
theorem provers today internally they
have a Sat solver and what they're doing
is they're taking the original problem
and encoding it to an equally
satisfiable sac problem okay and so so
basically if you want to be able to do
it assembly solving you have to be able
to do SAT solving effectively alright so
those are the three topics I'll talk
about today okay I'll talk about
structure in sat structure and smt and
and trying to understand you know why
invariant synthesis is effective all
right so and we'll see how you know how
far I'm able to go hopefully I'll be
able to cover all of these in a
reasonable amount of detail okay so um
so let's start with SAT right so the
question is why do SAT solvers work well
in practice we talked about this
yesterday a little bit at the discussion
and of course the sad community has been
thinking about this for a while and that
the hypothesis is that especially with
these industrial sad so sad instances
there must be some property right that
makes them easy if you can capture that
property then we can try to prove
something about it and one popular
proposal that was mentioned yesterday is
this idea of community structure so let
me tell you what that is
okay so the idea of community structure
actually comes from from graph studies
of graphs by not just computer scientist
but mathematicians and theoretical
physicists and the idea is that if you
have to have a graph and if you can
partition it into components where the
components themselves internally are
well connected but the components
between them are only sparsely connected
right then the idea is that this you can
think of this graph as being partitioned
into a bunch of communities internally
they are well connected but they're not
that greatly connected to each other
okay now one way of measuring camellia
structure is using a metric called
modularity which I will define in a few
slides it's also called the Q value
there are many metrics and in fact one
of the things that we studied over the
last year or so was trying to understand
what what would happen if we looked at a
variety of metrics that that measure
community structure for sat problems and
and the reason committee structure is is
so interesting in the sack context is
there's actually a considerable
experimental evidence that when you know
a certain graph that you can build from
the SAT problem called the variable
incidence graph when that has good
community structure so you know it's got
these components that are well connected
but only sparsely connected to each
other then the underlying SAT problems
tend to be easy to solve by the leading
approach to sac which is called conflict
driven Clause learning or cdcl okay for
purposes of the stock it's not so
important how cdcl works I mean I can
tell you more about that after the talk
but but all of these papers have given
lots and lots of data from the the
publicly available industrial benchmarks
showing that the seems to be community
media structure seems to be a good
explanation for why cdcl does well so in
particular here's one piece of
experimental data from this paper that
was at each guy last year now Q is this
measure of modularity
a high value of Q suffuses values
between 0 and 1 a high value of Q close
to 1 means that the structure is highly
modular right so very well connected
components with very sparse connections
between them a Q value that's low is one
where you don't really have this okay so
if you imagine things like random SAT
tend to be more like this now they
looked at two SAT solvers glucose which
was one of the champion SAT solvers in
cdcl of the CDI cell type at the time
and March which is a different SAT
solver that does well on random SAT
instances and what they found here is
that so they proposed a certain model
will study soon but what this what they
have seen is that when the instances are
highly modular the this solver the
look-ahead solver you know it doesn't do
well so it times out at 10,000 seconds
on many instances where as this the cdcl
solver basically finishes in all of them
within about you know a few thousand
seconds question yep is across learning
important in this result the correlation
just learning is cross learning is is an
important distinction between these two
yeah but no what I mean is this kind of
performance ah who are there's always
that don't use puzzling once I have it
good question because I don't the
comparison was only between these two
solvers so it's I think this is
empirically based on the other papers
this is also true that is high high
modularity is good for a number of cdcl
solvers I don't know if that holds for
whether it's bad for the other non cdcl
solvers that I don't know okay all right
yeah and so and you celo modularity here
is bad for for the cdcl solver because
it seems to be doing really bad but as
the other solvent is fine okay okay so
that's that's where we were last year
and so so over the last year my two of
my students undergrad and one of my
graduate students and I started to try
to understand make an attempt to
understand if we can prove or disprove
something about this you know that is to
say
can we say something in a theoretical
sense about cdcl performance and
community structure and so the first
thing we did is we generalize this
metric called modularity to a broader
class of metrics that we call polynomial
click metrics and discuss that and
basically showed that if you look at if
you try to define modular instances
according to any of these metrics then
the class of you know modular at
instances according to this metrics the
SAT problem remains NP hard for them
okay so basically it's not really
explaining everything and secondly the
the previous the the the folks who
presented the data that I showed in the
previous slide they actually proposed a
random modular SAT model similar to the
random casac model they have they
proposed a random modular casac model
and that was they generated instances
from that model and that was what the
previous slides data was from so so you
know this there was a question about
whether you can actually prove that that
cdcl will do will work efficiently on
that class of instances and and we
showed a hardness you know a negative
result basically saying that you know
with high probability the the inner
instance is going to be hard for cdcl in
the sense that if this is for unsat
instances so if you look at unsat
instance from this model then cdcl is
going to need an exponential time to
determine that is unsatisfiable
certificate modularity tends to one like
you know a graph that makes up into two
or three communities or like a small
number what if you had many many small
communities does that change these
results yeah so it's a good question so
I mean here you can see that the
conditional nature of our negative
result is if you have a small number of
communities than the result applies and
it's an open question although we have
some experimental evidence suggesting
that this result may extend even for
larger communities but it's still an
open theoretical question
okay so I at a high level the point that
the thing that we've become reasonably
convinced about is that the the
definitions of community structure as
the sax community is using it today are
not enough you need to refine them so so
let me go through a few definitions so
the graph abstraction of the sack
problem is something called the variable
incidence graph basically every node
corresponds to a variable and if two
variables appear in the same clause you
add an edge between them it's an
undirected graph okay and so we're going
to look at metrics on these on these
sorts of graphs and so in general a
graph metric is something that is a
function that map's a graph to a number
in 01 and so this modularity that is
been defined in the community is always
is a metric like this we're going to
denote by sac M comma epsilon the class
of sac formulas that have high
modularity according to this metric m so
basically em on the variable incidence
graph of the formula from this classf i
is greater than equal to 1 minus epsilon
for any specified parameter epsilon ok
so if fixed and epsilon you get a class
of formulas and so modularity is this
queue metric that i'll define soon so
when I say statque epsilon it's the
class of formulas with high modularity
as defined by the parameter epsilon okay
so what is the queue metric so I
consider the variable incidence graph of
some formula Phi and then consider a
partition of the vertices ok so Delta is
a partition that breaks gphi into n
components c1 through CN so then the q
value is defined as follows right so
it's the max over all partitions Delta
of this particular term so let's see
what that term is so if you look at this
first term it's basically so it's
defined for weighted graphs but you can
assume that the weights are one right
for the variable incidence graph and so
so this is basically the sum of overall
edges within a component see
divided by the total number of edges and
so basically this term the red term is
the fraction of edges that lie within
the communities and the second term is
essentially it's a it's based on the
degree of vertices and you if you work
it out it's it turns out to be the
expected fraction of edges that lie
within the communities if you maintain
the same degree distribution but you
randomly distribute the edges all right
so so it was previously observed I mean
this was not proof but it was observed
that that any CNF formula can be
polynomially transformed into an EP
satisfiable formula with arbitrary high
modularity and actually it's a very
simple construction ok but I'll show you
this in this next slide but the idea is
that you know if you can of course do
this then you can embed any sad problem
into a high modularity instance and
therefore the the set of all high
modularity instances according to Q is
np-hard ok and the idea is as follows
you take arbitrary SAT problem you
compute its variable incidence graph
let's say it's that and then you just
replicate it ok so basically if your
original formula was Phi then you make a
little see copies of Phi where
internally you rename the variables so
each of these copies the nodes you know
correspond to different variables but
basically they're all symmetric and you
can see that this new formula the
conjunction of Phi 1 through 5 c is
equal Attis fiable with the original one
right so satisfiability only if the
original one is satisfiable and but you
can also see that this is excellent from
a modularity perspective right very well
connected internally not connected at
all right and so so basically if you
work out the details and I won't go
through it this in gory detail but the
idea is that for this new formula Phi
prime you can work out that the
modularity is 1 over 1 minus a 1 1 minus
1 over the number of communities and if
you let the number of communities you
know increase with the number of
variables right then you can make it
arbitrary close to one right ok so so
that's about modularity and so the
Shin that was doing that you replicated
I mean you increase the size you I mean
the way I was looking at it is that your
community structure on your original
start problem is essentially giving you
almost decomposed ability so you're at
least intuitively you're solving the
you're solving the sack separately in
the community is a sort of some details
Iraq huh and you exploiting that weak
interaction do it but this seems like
you're replicating that's right so I'm
not this is not a solution strategy
right it's just basically this is
showing that that modularity is a bad
explanation right because you know
highly modular instances can be hard I
think the point is poly normal voice the
exponential right and that too right you
want to make polymer many many copies of
this many copies that won't change it
that's right yeah yes that's an
important point all right so so now we
can generalize this to actually a
broader class of metrics and the idea is
that you know modularity so the question
is you know maybe the Q function was a
weird thing right and if you define a
better metric then it that also captured
modularity in the intuitive sense then
maybe it that would be the right
explanation and so so we thought about
that and said okay what graphs have
ideal community structure right and can
we define a class of metrics that gives
a high value to these graphs and low
values to graphs that don't have the
structure and if you think about what
graphs have ha you know I can be a
structure then one extreme is to
basically look at at clicks and you know
basic you know collections of clicks
unconnected connections of flicks so if
i look at you know just a single click
then if that itself is the entire
variable incidence grass of course this
has poor community structure because
it's globally well connected but if i
take a click and i make many many copies
of that click you know polynomial many
copies of that click and don't connect
them up then this has ideally committee
structure right and so so we defined a
family of metrics that we call
polynomial click metrics and we'd only
have to read through the details but the
idea is that
a polynomial Creek metric is one that
gives you no large values for any
epsilon it gives you a model arity value
because then 1 minus epsilon for a
polymer mill connection of creeks ok and
essentially the previous transformation
that I showed from any arbitrary start
problems 22 you know a problem this is a
conjunction that that shows that
modularity is a PCM but it can also be
slightly tweaked to show that any
polynomial click metric any for any even
ask for any other pollen click metric
the you can take an arbitrary SAT
instance and embed it into an equal
satisfiable instance that is highly
modular according to that polynomial
click metric doesn't suggest a graph
structure can't help you because I can
take a hard instance and then put it in
the quadratically large graph with the
quadratically large graph has lots of
structure but it's avoiding the core
hardness that comes from this tiny
portion yeah I think in general the this
at least the variable incidence graph by
itself is not enough X and one important
thing that it ignores polarity which i
think is pretty important for sat but
but by itself also I don't think it's
enough there's a few other things that
you need and one thing that we feel is
important is the number of communities
and but but in fact i don't really know
have the answer to your question I mean
maybe Kevin and holger the people have
studied lots of sad instances can weigh
in and say what else might be necessary
okay so that's that's one result that is
you know for any PCM if you compute this
this class act M epsilon that's going to
be np-hard but but then we wanted to you
know dive in a bit deeper into just the
random sack model that was proposed last
year right from random modular SAT and
try to analyze you know if that is if
you can prove something about that and
so so let me tell you a little bit about
that particular result so so these
conflict driven Clause learning SAT
solvers cdcl SAT solvers all use a one
proof rule in coming up with a proof one
satisfiability which is resolution right
so the resolution proof rule essentially
is if you have two clauses which have a
the same variable but in opposite
polarities so be here and not be here
then you can derive from these two a new
clause that drops B&B and not be and but
keeps all the other difference right and
and then the proof run satisfiability
from a cdcl solver is essentially a
sequence of resolution rules
applications of resolution rules that
results in the empty clause being
derived okay that is you have BN not be
at some point and we derive the empty
clothes okay and because all cdcl
solvers at the core even they are
proving on satisfiability they are
essentially they're doing resolution the
the length of the the shortest
resolution proof is going to be a lower
bound for the runtime on unsat instances
right and so if we can show that for
some collection of CNF formulas from
some family of siena formulas if and
especially if they come from some random
model if we can show with high
probability the resolution proofs are
going to be exponential sized then we
know that cdcl is going to take
exponential time okay so so such as
analysis was already done for the
standard random sack model in the
90s so so you can think of the this the
set of random start formulas k sath
formulas is being represented by this so
it's fkn m n is number of variables m is
the number of clauses and k is the
number of literals in each clause and
let me skip that and so the result in
particular is by beam in petoskey from
96 which when i show that if you look at
this class of formulas okay then it
requires exponentially long resolution
reputations okay with high probability
defined over the distribution of romulus
and so the we basically what we did is
we took the model proposed last year
which i'll explain in a slide and
essentially proved the same theorem for
it we took diamond pet aziz proof
technique and just adapted it for the
new model okay and so what is this new
model it's called the community
attachment model and it's the one from
which I showed the data earlier and the
way you construct formulas is as follows
so you have two more parameters C for
the number of communities and P for a
probability that a clause is inside a
community or or across communities and
the way it works is you fix a set of
variables and then you fix a number of
communities and you make them even okay
and then you're generating clauses right
and so for M iterations with probability
you could toss a coin and if it comes up
head then you add a clause within a
community okay with K literals if it
comes up tails then you add a clause
that bridges communities that has one
literal from each community and so these
clauses are called community clauses
these classes are called bridge clauses
and so your overall sad problem ends up
being a combination of community clauses
and bridge closes okay so I'll just skip
through this in the interest of time and
so basically our theorem is that if you
look at the following family so the
number of clauses is of the order of
number of variables the number of
community
is is small in the sense it's about n
raised to point one okay then that a
random modular family will requires
exponentially long resolution
reputations with high probability okay
and this holds for all p right so at p
is this parameter which decides whether
something is to be added inside a
community or across communities sorry so
yeah those are not standard models for
communities I mean this is not quite
preferential attachment it's not quite
preferential attachment what is
preferential attachment the provincial
attachments model stroke minis are more
like noon or comes in and then oh I see
okay okay I see what you mean oh this is
probably not yeah yeah so I mean again
the term community attachment model is
something that the authors of the paper
the sky paper last you are used so I'm
not it may have been that this that
phrase is used in a different context by
by others and so anyway so I mean all
I'm saying is this is it is a committed
it is no that's right indeed yeah okay
but I think for in the context of this
work it's the model which empirically
was shown to have good good positive
correlation with the performance of CDC
LSAT and what this is essentially
showing is that when the number of
communities is small relative to the
number of variables right then you know
that it doesn't really explain things
okay okay so
I see that I'm going short on time so i
will i'll just you know wrap up this
okay so i think i want to talk about
this slide so there's a number of
questions that I think this initial work
is thrown up like we just basically did
this investigation over the last year
and I think we have more questions than
answers yeah so the first is of course
you know can we define a better measure
the second is actually trying to improve
our result so our result only holds for
the number of communities that's you
know of n raise to point one and in
particular we don't do anything
interesting with this parameter P and so
we're interested in seeing if our result
can be improved by a result that
actually uses some properties of the of
the parameter P and of course in
particular what we're interested in
doing is trying to extend the result
where the comfort of communities grows
bigger than 0 point one right and raise
2.1 okay and in particular a related
question is you know can we do some
experimentation to find out what happens
as I grow the number of communities
relative to the number of variables and
so so let me actually show some very
preliminary data on that but I have to
admit I don't really do a lot of these
large-scale SAT benchmarking experiments
there are others in the room who have
more experience with that and so this is
very very primary so the idea is what we
did is we on the x-axis we varied
community size and we did this for
fixing the the relation of number of
communities to number of variables based
on this parameter alpha so the number of
communities is n raised to alpha n is
number of variables and we buried also
from point 1 2.4 so remember that point
one is basically threshold at which are
negative result holds so we're trying to
see what happens as you go higher and
the running time of a cdcl SAT solver
mini SAT is on the y-axis in log scale
and so what we are seeing here is that
you know for all of these values of
alpha the runtime grows linearly
exponentially with the community strives
okay and so there is still exponential
growth in the runtime for even as you
increase alpha but what you can see is
actually that all of these are bunched
up pretty closely which means that for
higher values of alpha in some sense you
have to go further out if look at larger
instances to see the real blow up in
runtime and furthermore it it seems to
be that the size of communities seems to
be a stronger determinant of the runtime
then sort of the overall size of the
instance right and so maybe that's a
pointer to how to how to define the
model because the model as it is doesn't
really take the size of the community
into account in trying to predict the
runtime ok so I'm a little bit over 1050
how much time do I have Devon ok great
so I have a few more things to talk
about and I'll have to make a choice
here but let me let me give you a like a
one slide overview of this and then i'll
talk more about the invariant synthesis
which i think is it has a different link
to learning theory and i want to explore
that link along with this audience so so
so again so now let's switch from sat to
smt because you know for a lot of
problems you start not necessarily with
a sad problem but you start with the
problem that involves these richer types
and in particular oops the one of the
very useful theories logical theories
and program verification is is in linear
integer arithmetic right so it's
basically arbitrary boolean combinations
of affine constraints over integer
variables ok so this is I mean it's
basically like a disjunctions of integer
linear programs right and just looking
at feasibility questions but the the
reason this is
usually integer programming solvers
don't really do well on these on these
sorts of formulas that come from
verification and the reason is that they
have very rich boolean structure which
SAT based techniques do much better on
okay now so this problem is is is
np-complete and one of the techniques
that have been found quite effective is
this idea called small domain encoding
okay now initially it may seem a little
counterintuitive to many of you but but
actually you know trust me this works
really well okay so the way this works
is you have a formula over n variables
they're all integer variables so so each
exile I zinzie what you do is you find a
a set of values s I which is a subset of
the domain and it is usually you know
small finite subset much much smaller
than the size of the domain okay and
then what you do is you restrict your
search for for satisfying solutions to
just the s eyes okay and one way to do
that is you encode each of the integer
variables as a finite position integer
that takes values only in this set and
then you translate the overall formula
into a sack problem and you give it off
to a Sat solver and so and and there are
variants I mean this is one encoding
called small domain and coatings there
are other encoding is that SMT solvers
use and they all translate to start
exploiting these sorts of things all
right so so now clearly the size of this
domain is important right because in
general if your domain size is really
large right even though the number of
bits in your in your sad problem is
logarithmic in the domain size still you
know this can be really you have to be
you have to be careful to make sure that
you find speaks of it these are really
small domains okay and so in general you
know a lot of these bounds come from it
originally came from the proofs that
integer linear programming is in NP
right so you have a small simple anomaly
bounded satisfying solution in the
number of bits and so this is one such
bound that from a paper by christos and
you can see that if you take
log of this where m is the number of
inequalities n is the number of
variables V Max is the largest constant
term and a max is the largest
coefficient right if you take log of
this it's a polynomial but as you know
as a number it's pretty large because
you can think of em as in the thousands
so you have thousand raised two thousand
right so the size of the domain here is
not something that you were really
ordinarily want to search on all right
so so the reason I'm talking about it
here in the presentation is that really
what we've done in the verification
community is we have studied the
structure of linear constraints that
come from program verification and
hardware verification and it turns out
to be not arbitrary linear constraints
okay so one special case that's been
well studied is if you what if you had
just equalities and you may say well
that seems really like a really dumb
stupid class but it shows up amazingly
often I mean most of the inequalities
most of these these linear constraints
re qualities because in a program for
instance every assignment in the program
becomes an equality and many of them are
just relating this copying things around
okay and it turns out for that the size
of the domain is just number of
variables yeah equality between two
variables yeah or in general two terms I
mean they can be one side can be like an
array axis or things like that but ok so
I'm again in the interest of time I'm
going to skip over some of this and I'll
show a summary table but I think this is
perhaps the most interesting slide so we
did a pretty exhaustive study this is of
course almost 10 years old now of what
kinds of linear constraints show up in
verification and we stopped we found two
characteristics one is that they are
mostly difference bound constraints so
there are constraints of the form X I
minus XJ greater than equal to a
constant okay and and even those that
are not difference constraints are very
sparse so you know if I think of a 1 X 1
plus a 2 x 2 2 a n xn most of the AIS
are zeros right and the and those that
are not 0 10
to be small okay and so basically you
can exploit that so this is you know you
introduce new parameters for the number
of non difference constraints and to
measure sparsity like how many variables
are there per constraint and this bound
that I showed you earlier simplifies
very nicely so the exponent goes from a
linear function of the number of
constraints to simply the number of non
difference constraints and then in the
base again M gets replaced by the number
of variables the maximum number of
variables in any constraint that has
nonzero coefficients we observe this in
practice and then we introduced these
two parameters and proved a new bound
okay that is if you're you want to bound
the the the size of a set of solutions
such that if there's no solution in this
set and there's no solution at all right
you want to find that bound it
simplifies as follows all right so so in
fact I mean for and we have a range of
different things so qualities difference
bound constraints and there's something
called octagons that our talk about next
which is also very similar and then
fully integer linear charismatic and so
and this is one of the reasons why you
know solving it is early arithmetic in
the SMT community is this now it's a
salt problem it make routinely done very
big formulas and I really what's
happening is there on solving arbitrary
linear constraints ok so I'll finish up
with one last thing which is very new
but it has some links to machine
learning theory and actually has this
genesis of this work is in a
conversation Avram and i had when i was
at CMU 15 years ago so this is about
learning program invariance so if you
look at the previous example the problem
was to find a loop invariant and it
turns out this in this is the loop
invariant that works here x + y less
than equal to C so you can see it's true
initially and every time you go down
over the loop x
gets decremented and why maybe gets
incremented right now this constraint is
what is called an octagon constraint so
it's an octagon constraint is is a
generalization of difference bound
constraints where the coefficients can
be plus or minus one this order you know
45-degree hyper planes that then mention
two variables and why is octagon
constrained interesting well in the work
that I mentioned previously done for
Airbus so there's a there's a program
verification tool called astray has been
developed in France they did an
extensive evaluation and found that too
in order to infer and variance octagons
in the class of linear inequalities
called octagons was the perfect balance
in terms of automatically inferring
these and then being able to prove it on
you know millions of lines of code okay
it has to be generated is inferred so it
has to be you know yeah so how it is
generated varies depending on the
technique but but one of the big one of
the big ways that in recently people
have been doing it is learning in
variance from from test data right and
so really the way it works is you give a
bunch of test cases and you find what
are some likely invariants just by
learning relationships that are
consistent with your test data and then
you you invoke a theorem prover to try
to prove that indeed it's in it's a
valid loop invariant and if it succeeds
you're done you're done you have a loop
invariant but if not you get a counter
example which is again a test case that
tells you why this is not an invariant
and you add that back in your set and
you iterate this right and so this
actually this this process looks very
much like query based learning because
you can think of the invariance of this
technique as a learner and the solver as
the the teacher or the Oracle that
answers you know correctness queries and
gives counter examples right if if it's
not correct and so the obvious question
is how many iterations do you need
because potentially every call to your
theorem prover is a little expensive
right and so you want to do this quickly
when it converge quickly
okay and so it turns out this is related
to this idea of teaching dimension from
from learning theory which is
essentially is you know if there's a
teacher who knows a concept and they
want to convey the concept was to
students by just using labeled examples
then what's the minimum number of
examples they need to convey any concept
from a concept class right and this best
look understood looking at an example so
this is an example from the Goulburn
currents paper that I cited earlier if
you want if the teacher has to teach a
two dimensional box that's lying on a
grid then and but they can only give
examples labeled examples of the grid
then this is an optimal teaching set
right so you say that the diagonally
opposite corners are positive examples
then they're outside nearest neighbors
are negative examples right and in is
this in two dimensions and in D
dimensions this the construction extends
so used to you have the diagonally
opposite corners and then you have the D
neighbors on each side so it's 2 D plus
2 all right now what's interesting about
this is that hyper boxes correspond to a
very simple class of inequalities which
are just bounds so if I have program
variables that this lie between upper
and lower bounds then then you know the
conjunction of such inequalities is
going to be a hyper box right and these
are these appear in things like array
bounds checks and so simple program
invariance but they're not enough in
general and so so that's where we
started and so the one of the things is
that it's easy to see that the teaching
dimension is a lower bound on the number
of interactions you have between the
learner and the teacher and so what we
looked at was what is the teaching
dimension for octagon constraints
because it's you know in program
verification octagon constrains seems to
be a class that's found to be quite
useful and so you know I'll skip over
this but basically the idea is here you
can visualize in 2d and say well you
know how many points do I need in the
same way as a rectangle so that I can I
i define this
octagon exactly but I can't move it in
or out and it turns out that you can do
this with for positive examples and
eight negative examples and the idea is
that the the positive examples are
vertices that cover all the faces a
covering set and then the negative
examples are points that essentially
disallow you from moving these faces
anymore outward and it generalizes
nicely so we've been able to prove that
for D dimensions the teaching dimension
of octagons is is to D plus 2 d squared
ok and so now thinking back in the
context of program invariant synthesis
what this is telling us is that so d is
the number of variables in your
invariant and in program verification
what happens is that invariants tend to
be over programs that variables that are
in scope at that point in the program
and so even though your program may have
you know thousands of variables usually
if it's well-written the number of
variables in scope at any given point of
time is much smaller it's on order of 10
right and that's what D is and so and
you know empirically people have found
that octagon constraints are easy to
infer with just a few test cases and so
this seems to be a sort of a theoretical
explanation of why that might be
happening because really the teaching
dimension of octagons is actually is
polynomial right ok so again I mean this
is very very preliminary so I think
there's a lot more to be done and this
is all teaching dimension is only a
lower bound so we still want ways to
understand and upper bound techniques
that are used for invariant influence
alright so that's the the summary so I
talked about three things sat solving is
really the core computational problem in
verification and although community
structure is a promising start we need
more smt solving I think it's really
ridden on the on ways of exploiting
special structure of constraints that
are as in verification and then
invariance synthesis
i think is there's a there's a growing
sub-community that work on invariant
synthesis who are interested in using
techniques from learning and i think
what's really interesting is to
understand why these techniques are
doing well from by leveraging ideas from
learning theory so with that let's stop
you thank you one thing so there's a
bright starting 15 minutes ago going
until 11 20 so maybe we just have
questions over the over the coffee how
about let's do that lets thank Shawne do
together